on va passer au témoin du jour on va
recevoir dans un instant Jean-Louis Jean
Jean-Louis qui habite dans le vou le Me
Jean-Louis mais c'est vrai
JeanLouis mais non c'est toi ça a dit
JeanLouis non pas maintenant là tu
sors Jeanlou ça va ça va va bien non non
mais les gars oh Jean-Louis va
bien pas drame avecou ça va pr un
tractopel parce qu'il éit excédé c'est
tout pas de ouf non mais c'est vra il y
a pas de ouf voilà les gars c'est pas
dramatique l'histoire ça va donc on
vaevoir
Jean-Louis il habite dans le Var donc
Jean-Louis il est propriétairein
c'est mort to tu une parcelle est
squat une parcelle est squatteré depuis
plusieurs années il est en colère
Jean-Louis c'est mort mais ça fait c'est
mort non mais jeanou compliqué qui va
venir dans un
instant
sors plus loin plus loin donc Jean-Louis
a décidé de d'éloger les squatters est
la sortie
est
est ou on s'en doute qu'il est là il
vair est là alors on est très content
d'accueillir Jean-Louis ce soir regardez
la colère de Jean-Louis qui a donc il y
a en fait il a décidé d'employer Laur
pour déloger le squatter il a sorti le
tractopel samedi dernier pour tenter de
son
bien ça va être dur ça va être long
cette
séquence de plusieurs soutiens
regarde en l'individu ENL
l'individu un par bras un par
[Musique]
jamb
as bien fait bravo Jean-Louis jel
bonsoir qui va pas êre d'accord AC toi
je pens
g je suis d'accord avec toi
jeanou
jeou merci d'être avec
nousêes agriculteur propriétaire terrain
de plus de 3 et ce terrain est squé
depuis plusieurs années comment il até
squé comment il sont sont arrivés
disons que j'ai j'ai commencé par louer
à à sa concubine d'accord au bout de
quelques années Ben
est partie bon et puis depuis que
Monsieur remémy bataglia a pris le bail
B il s'est jamais honoré de quoi que ce
soit il a arrêté en fait de payer c'est
ça qu'il a été 2019 voilà donc vous avez
eu il faut le dire deux décisions de
justice en votre faveur et il y a eu une
procédure d'expulsion 72 he qui a été
décidée mais pas appliqué et donc vous
avez décidé à ce moment-là vous
d'utiliser la manière forte si je pu
dire un tractopel c'est ça ça oui oui
non mais c'est pas marrant parce que
bon oui pourquoi parce qu'en fait à la
fin de des 2 mois oui où il avait pour
déménager ouais bah il me il me met de
procédures deux assignations oui pour
pour continuer pour partir en justice
contre moi quoi d'accord et moi comme ça
fait 3 ans et demi que je peux pas
rentrer sur le site et prouver toutes
ces ces actions arrachage de 300 figué
euh ramblément de 7000 tonnes 700
camions ça vous parle un peu non un peu
quand même euh démolition der
systématique plusieurs centaines de
mètres carrés de verre euh le chauffage
l'arrosage dessert donc voilà son but
c'est de faire des hangars pour louer
hangars quo il y a quelque chose qu'on a
pas compris en fait sur les images c'est
qu'on voit ce qu' y avait derrière Cyril
on voit que quand vous arrivez il y a
plusieurs personnes avec l'ancien
locataire c'est-àdire qu'il y a d'autres
gens qui sont venus s'installer sur le
terrain apparemment ce qui c'est on m'a
interdit de rentrer oui le 2 novembre
sur mon terrain parce que on me r les
clés le 2 novembre à 9h et à 10h
apparemment il y avait d'autres
personnes chez moi c'est qui c'est des
am de l'ancien loc ça faut demander à à
la gendarmerie qui a fait le F barage
ils font barrage pour vous empêcher de
c'est ça pourquoi parce que ben parce
qu'il y a tellement de choses à
découvrir chez moi que n'importe quoi ça
que que voilà on veut pas que je pénètre
et que je fasse constater moi pour les
prochaines procédures il me faut avoir
une constatation duier et personne
personne me laisse rentrer donc là là
mon
objectif c'était de squatter mon
ouais alors une propriété agricole en
France n'est pas involable bien sûr une
habitation oui mais pas une propriété
agricole donc moi je me suis je suis
arrivé devant un portail qui en théorie
avait des cailloux devant c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait un dractopel des cailloux
derrière le portail et quand on est
arrivé samedi bah c'était un camion et
donc ces personnes là se mettent sur le
camion bien sûr pour pour bien sûr bon
nous n êch d'avancer et bon la
jeendarmerie était là bien sûr pour pour
pour pour voilà mais vous auriez été
jusqu'ù avec votre tractopel vous auriez
arraché le portail vous seriez rentré
bien sûr et j'aurais poussé les cailloux
et je serais rentré on avait tout prévu
pour euh caravane camping-car tante pour
être sur place pour pouvoir prouver tout
ce qui a été fait depuis 4 par par cette
personne monsieur batagilia moi
aujourd'hui je peux pas le prouver on M
interdit de de de de de prouver tout ça
alors comment je fais comment je vais en
justice le 8 décembre comment j'y vais
il dit que lui dit que lui il est c'est
c'est il dit que en réalité un
propriétaire l'a arnaqué depuis
plusieurs dizaines de de milliers
d'euros de dizaines que la personne qui
squat dit que c'est en fait il a été en
réalité lui-même arnaqué voilà bah c'est
faux ça c'est sûr c'est faux bah bien
sûr moi alors c'est c'est plus personne
paye les lous en France enedis m'a
appelé qui paye pas cité bon
continue il peut pas y avoir un constat
d'hissier qui a non pas vous mais vous
accompagne pour
allerf j'elle ça un peu de
l'administration des pouvoirs public
font pas moi personne aujourd'hui
réc Mar t il y a eu deux décisions de
justice et là vous voulez faire venir
encore un autre mec il y a eu deux
décision par que Monsieur retourne en
justice le
il fa
combien combi de décision de justice
c'est ça pour lui pour pour lui il faut
plusieurs décisions de justice et pour
pour votre ami Éric dupontti il en faut
il en a fallu qu'une ou votre am vous
non mais c'est oui j'entends j'entends
mais c'est vrai oui j'entends oui oui
j'ai oui oui c'est c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce que comme vous le disiez
le locataire estime que son ex concubine
a acheté le terrain donc d'ailleurs il y
aura un procès comme disait Valérie en
janvier est-ce que vous êes non non la
procédure c'est sur un soit-disant
compromis oui TI un pote un pote jembre
s ditembrasse mon frérot qui me dit la
justice vire pas les squatters et moi la
justice ve débouler ma maison c'est vra
en PU qu'il a fait une maison fabuleuse
exceptionnel voilà et ils veulent lui
démolir donc je mais les squatters ils
ont tous les droits et là en fait
Jean-Louis il a utilisé entre guillemets
les méthodes des squatters qui consiste
à rentrer par effraction dans sa propre
maison mais quand c'est un propriétaire
qui le fait ça choque tout le monde
quand c'est des squatters tout le monde
trouve ça normal en fait il y a un truc
social làdans c'est qu'on se range
derrière les locataires pour dire que
c'est des pauvres gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se loger et cetera et les
propriétaires qui ne sont pas toujours
des gens riches fortunés et qui ont 15
maisons eux se font défoncer par la
justice et se font engueuler quand ils
veulent juste trouver le bien regardez
que la vidéo vous en prenez au portail
regardez j'en peux plus quoi c'est c'est
c'est c'est pas possible ça tête de Dieu
c'est pas
possible pas possible [__] de
merde c'est mon terrain c'est mon
terrain c'est mon terrain
je non comment on peut accepter de bien
sûr dire c'est mon terrain mais
n'importe quoi c'est quoi ça c'est
impossible quoi d'accepter ça c'est par
que vous avez des difficultés
financières à cause de ça maintenant ah
ben bien sûr ah oui moi je suis à plus
200000 € qui aujourd'hui dans la salle
quand vous parliez tout à l'heure de
combien il faut gagner sû vous mais
200000 € 100000 € en 4 ans moi j'ai un
crédit dessus je peux plus le payer bien
sûr demander à ma banque je peux plus
payer c'est c'est inadmissible et ça va
arriver ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour vous qu'est-ce qu'on a envie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aider dites-nous moi je veux rentrer sur
sur place pour faire voir que cette
terre nourricière qui est quand même une
des meilleures d'Europe c'est pas rien
quand même une des meilleures terres
d'Europe a été ramblayé par des épaves
il y a il y a au moins encore 30 ou 40
épaves des pneus 7000 tonnes de ramelé
euh des seres toutes démolies et plus de
système de r pu et et et tout ça je dois
je je dois et et c'est et c'est moi le
c'est moi le bandit c'est moi le méchant
c'est n'importe quoi parfait c'est
n'importe quoi Jean continu on va
essayer de faire bouger les choses euh
vraiment
en médiatisant vraiment ce encore une
fois ce soir ce squat
qui je remercie quand même tous les gens
qui on été là parce tous les gens qui on
ét
avec on va se battre et on va essayer
parce que j'en peux plus quoi
c'est c'est pas permis quoi tout ça
c'est pas permis Jean-Louis faut garder
espoir Jean-Louis faut garder espoir il
faut faut et et et si vous allez vous en
sortir je suis sûr que il va avoir une
décision qui va être prise àez vite Gill
quand vous voyez ça franchement moi moi
je vous dire la vérité on n peut plus
des affaires comme ça moi je vous dis
franchement on n peut plus les les
Français ils deviennent fous on en
parlit tout à l'heure et on nous dit que
tout va bien dans le pays arrêtez moi
quand je vois Jean-Louis en pleur qui
qui qui qui arrive pas à s'en sortir à
cause d'un un mec qui lu a squatteré son
terrain les lois ne vont pas je suis
désolé faut êre s les lois ne vont pas
et qu'est-ce qui se passe après
Jean-Louis un moment il craque regarde
ah ouais non mais moi va faire quoi par
là Ilou
voilà il
fon plus
il fait quoi parce que l'autre va porter
plinte contre lui et lui il va faire
quoi c'est propriétaire qui paye
beaucoup je connais les les senten 30000
€ d'amende et 3 ans de prison moi
c'était pas pour déloger mon scotteur
moi c'était pour être sur place et juste
vérifier toutes les mal tout ce qu'il a
fait ce qui est fou c'est parce qu'il
est solvable il est solevable il paye
des au il travaille alors lui on peut
lui taper dessus mais le mec qui squat
et car rien qu'on peut rien lui prendre
on laisse
TR et surtout ce qui est fout c'est
qu'on prend des pincettes avec les
squats même lui dit je veux surtout pas
les déloger mais pardon mais si il faut
les déloger tu
P directement mais il faut que le
système les déloges tu ne payes pas
situation il d'analyser la situation il
devait le faire à partir du 2 novembre
sous 72 he rappelez-moi que les jour on
et c'est un appel à l'anarchie les gens
ils se disent pas en voyant ça on p not
Toer tout
monde merci en tout cas merci Jean-Louis
et on espère que l'affaire va avancer on
va tout faire pour ça avance dans le bon
sens pour vous et JeanLouis on continue
on B on lâche pas on est avec vous à
fond et tous les gens qui sont avec vous
franchement déjà c'est beau la la
solidarité autourci à tous merci
Jean-Louis